when i talk about the finite uh the
finite trend
the trend towards finite mindedness in
business over the past
you know 30 40 years uh you you can show
the exact same correlation in politics
um uh where politics and politicians
have become more short-term focused and
more finite-minded as well
and just like in businesses we've become
more focused on the product rather than
the vision
so too have politicians become more
focused on a single issue or a single
idea
rather than the context within which
that idea exists
um i i i haven't it's not that those
ideas are right or wrong or good or bad
my question is to what end like what
vision
does that idea serve because the ideas
that they propose
are strategies the strategies to get
towards something
get towards what and what's missing from
all of our politicians
for and this is not a republican or
democrat thing this has been for years
what's mission from all missing from all
of our politicians is distant
idealized sort of inspirational vision
whether you're a democrat or a
republican you could have listened to
ronald reagan's inaugural address
or you could have listened to john f
kennedy's inaugural address and they
both talked about world peace peace on
earth
like even saying those words now sounds
ridiculous
but that's a wonderful thing to talk
about the dream i have a dream of a
distant future
that we should commit ourselves to work
towards one slow step at a time
and i think what's missing from all of
them is they're hoping to
garner favor by people who like the one
idea because it resonates with me
and they're trying to pick the idea that
resonates with the most people so they
can get elected
and it's not that the ideas are right or
wrong but i want to know to what end
what's the bigger vision